من بدايه السنه واسم الفنان المصري شيرين
عبد الوهاب متصدر التراند وكثير مرات كمان
بالخط الاحمر سنه كانت فيها شيرين عم
بتعيش حياتها الشخصيه بكل تفاصيلها مع
العالم من لحظه اعلان انفصالها عن زوجها
حسام حبيب التي هي مع عائلتها لها
بالطاعاتي لدخولها المستشفى وصولا لاعلان
زواجها مره ثانيه من طليقه لكن جديد شيرين
هو فيديو ظهرت فيه بملهى ليلي بلبنان مع
زوجها حسام وابنتها وكانت في حاله سعاده
ما بتوصف خلونا نشوف مع بعض
ههه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مبسوطه كثير مثل ما شفتوا شيرين كانت عم
تتصرف بطريقه شوي غريبه او يمكن بعفويه
لكن العالم ما صدقت وشافت شيء جديد لشيرين
والموضوع عمل جدل ومجددا عرضها طبعا كثير
من الانتقادات الواسعه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي خلونا نشوف بعض هذه الانتقادات